servus skills und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video heute spielen wir
minecraft singleplayer ja genau
einfach bisschen minecraft singleplayer
ganz billig und wahrscheinlich warum sie
so komisch laufe und nicht stattfinden
kann und ihr fach ich wahrscheinlich
warum minecraft heute so die fertig
aussieht dazu gleich mehr wir schauen
erst mal kurz in tempera genau das ist
auch der abt a1 gesehen des heutigen
videos dass wir einfach hierfür sind im
tempel schauen vielleicht nicht news
machen auf jeden fall trocken dann
einfach mal reinschauen so das motto ok
alles klar
diamanten reisen ewigen magic boston
terrier wieder raus denn der wahre grund
des heutigen videos liegt hinter den
wüsten steppen und zwar in der richtung
aus der bulgarischen gekommen sind weiß
man nicht zu viel steuern deswegen
schauen wir mal kurz auf dem bodenwert
wieder laufen
das gras ist halt auch sehr des grases
grünen sehr grünes gras wir haben auch
einen kleinen spaziergang durch wald und
ganz unscheinbar die erste mal hier geht
man glaube ich mal so ein bisschen links
sind hier lang eventuell könnte sich auf
der linken seite hinter dem weiter
irgendwas verbergen und hier kann man
nur auf dem boden schaut dafür weiter
wie western ja hier rang und ok was sind
das für blöcke ja leute das ist ein
funktionsfähiger pc genau wie hat ein
funktionsfähiger mac in minecraft und
irgend jemand hat auf diesem weg schon
eine botschaft hinterlassen
ja dieses ding habe ich heute gerade
entdeckt ich bin um halb eins aus der
uni nach hause gekommen nachts natürlich
und habe mir bislang mit schild auf
youtube und hat dann einfach ein video
hier über irgendwie gefunden das ewig
als drei jahre alt oder so bradford
opiat vorgestellt so komisch märz
vorgestellt luca hat vor zwei jahren ein
video über einen mord gemacht das ist
kein mord des warner minecraft hier ja
irgendwann niemand vorgestellt und ich
fand das ding einfach so cool dass ich
mir dachte ok kommen aber machen wir
einfach mal ein video und ich hoffe es
gefällt ich auch so gut wie es mir
gefallen hat
es ist eine richtig richtig geile sache
und zwar haben wir hier eine tastatur
das ist eine amerikanische lustigerweise
weil er nicht ach du scheiße gold mops
auf der tastatur
oh gott oh gott bitte verbrennen laufen
ist die tastatur bitte doch nicht wie
bei uns drauf danke gewohnten glaub ich
drauf nein nein nein
finger weg von hollywood bitte ok leute
wer ist ein krieger tastatur das macht
die bedienung bisschen schwieriger würde
ich sagen aber auf jeden fall was ich
sagen wollte geben amerikanische werden
der deutschen wir die akku wr tz stehen
das ist quatsch amerikanische aber genug
ist das minecraft musik wann habe ich
zum letzten mal minecraft musik an
gehabt wo steht auch schrittes auf
also jetzt etwas kaputt gemacht hier
erzählen wir hoffen mal dass ihr
köpfchen nichts kaputt gemacht hat alles
klar dass wir das was war ist super hier
strich strich wir haben hier zahlen von
1 bis 90 auch hier mir klammern aus
solchen fragezeichen weil sie eine voll
funktionsfähige tastatur und wir gucken
jetzt mal hinten an dieses ding dann und
jetzt können auch die frage auf lösen
warum minecraft so komisch aussieht
fischer springen kann
die ganze sache spielt sich nämlich in
der 1.4 punkt 2 ab und je mehr
stromkabel hier auf jeden begeistert
irgendwie ein bisschen und das schon
kabel an sich in den berg gesteckt
einfach den stecker von dem pc nehmen zu
denen ein haufen erde zu schwein stecken
also strom für einen gigantischen berg
würde jemals strom braucht sich einfach
ein erdhaufen unterpreppach einstecken
da kann nichts schiefgehen was ich euch
zeigen wollte hier auf der rückseite auf
der unteren rechten ecke der rückseite
ist der power knopf vier wunderschön
dekoriert und zwar wenn wir den drücken
geht die fackel da oben aus und ist der
gesamte pc aus wenn wir jetzt mal
drücken die die knopf gut bedeutet dann
geht die fakten wieder an und der pcs
wieder an und er sollte sich jetzt
hätten wir gucken aber brav ab teilte
mir so gestört für die markierung
fliegen
jetzt ist hans meyer aber wir müssen
jetzt mal anschaut ist es so krass ist
einfach alles kloster blöcke hier und
die blinken und ich frage mich wie kann
ein mensch was bauen es einfach
kostenblöcke wie blinken dass sie auf
eingaben auf der tastatur da unten
reagieren ist vollkommen krass und ja
leute wenn man so einen großen pcs immer
so eine große fläche hat auf der man
etwas darstellen kann
was der welt mitteilen kann da muss man
sich überlegen was man sagen will
da muss man sich überlegen was ist die
botschaft gibt mich selbst überdauern
soll was ich die botschaft die mine
nachfahren allen erdbewohnern die nach
mehr auf dieser erde leben mitteilen
was möchten aliens mitteilen sie auf der
erde einfallen und alle menschen
verstarben kurz gesagt wenn ich eine
möglichkeit habe eine sache zu sagen
in meinem ganzen leben welche sache
würde das seien leute und diese
botschaft an einem nachfahrenden dann
alle menschen dieser welt nichts
geringeres als
ich bin einfach drei jahre alt in meinem
kopf ist so schlimm machen
mein körper ist 20 jahre alt ich bin
geistig einfach drei jahre alt und ja
das ist die botschaft die ich der
nachwelt übermitteln möchte und sophie
ziert die ganze geschichte aber ihr
lauft quasi über die einzelnen
druckplatten hier drüber dann erscheint
da oben ein buchstabe zum beispiel wenn
man jetzt hier über das die laufend
ergibt sich noch ein sinnvolles wort man
läuft quasi nur über eine druckplatte
darüber nicht über mehrere auf einmal
auf das über folgt dass das thema
scheint und ihr müsst auch relativ
langsam sein heißt ihr lauf quasi einmal
drüber dann wartet ihr eine ganze weile
dann formt sich langsam der buchstabe so
über uns jetzt und dann steht sexy auf
eurem mac in micro was ich habe schon
mal gesagt ich fand die sache einfach so
cool dass ich ihr euch unbedingt zeigen
wollte ich hoffe ihr habt die noch nicht
so gesehen in irgendeiner form und
findet ihr auch so cool wie ich war ja
ich frage mich wo kommt die neue lehr
freigiebig oder ist einfach eine fucking
kuh auf der nullwert dir eigentlich
erlaubt die drauf um zu tanzen muss gar
nicht wegdrehen jede rüben spielt die
musik was machst du auf meiner tastatur
hier seht ihr das
vor meinen augen läufst du nochmal
drüber weiß was du wirst du kannst du
wirst du kannst der link zur genannten
projektes und in der beschreibung und
der erbauer hat wirklich allen respekt
verdient lasse mir ob ich auf jeden fall
ein like dabei seine user hat oder so
abonniert ihn keine ahnung schickte
blumen kekse bionade hat was er möchte
weil das hier einfach krass ist guckt
euch das an leute das ist quasi eine
einzige große redstone zeitung
es ist so gestört seht ihr das das sind
150 200 300 blöcke in höhe und es geht
hier einfach immer weiter über redstone
überall redstone das alles aufeinander
abzustimmen das muss so viele arbeit
sein
und ja das war es auch schon von heute
von mir ich hoffe euch hat das mir
gefallen wenn ja dann lasst like da